- I heard too recently,
I didn't get to see it
but I've heard everybody talking about it
when Taylor surprised and
Kelce was on there as well.
Was that, I mean, 'cause that's hilarious
how the commentators.
It's not hilarious how it is
literally taking over the NFL
for people that like watching sports now.
- And like, you have to watch
like a tutorial on football.
- It's like you're watching "Housewives,"
while you're watching, yeah.
They're just talking about gossip things
and you're like, so what about the play?
- [Bowen] Right.
- Yes, yes.
- I can only imagine.
- [Kelly] But they're taking over.
- Right.
Definitely.
- Yeah, I thought
it was funny that y'all,
that's what I love about SNL,
y'all touch on it like right then.
It's so awesome that it's live
and you're able to like attack
those things on the weekends,
like right when it happens.
- [Bowen] Right.
- Yeah.
- [Bowen] It was crazy.
No one told us---
- Thank them
for fresh material.
- Oh yes, yes.
Thank you Travis and Taylor for that.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- It was so wild.
We didn't expect them to come.
I round the corner,
they're at the page desk
and I'm like, "Oh, there's two
"of the tallest people I've ever seen.
"Who are those?"
- Right.
- Who is that?
I was like in the Redwood
Forest or something.
(Kelly laughing)
- The mirror woods.
- Yes, yes.
And then I was like, oh my goodness.
Wow, it's them.
Okay, they're here.
And it was wild.
- Oh, I love it.
So, you went to her Eras Tour, right?
- Yes, I went to her, yeah.
- I wasn't able to make it
so I imagine it was just, first of all,
it's such a clever idea to
do that and have everybody go
'cause there's so much nostalgia happening
for people that have
been fans for so long.
- [Bowen] Yep.
- Have you been a fan for like a minute?
- I've been a fan for a long minute.
A long minute.
- [Kelly] Were you afraid to say decade?
(Bowen laughing)
- Wait, it's been about a decade,
'cause I really, yeah,
I latched on during Red.
- [Kelly] Oh, great album.
- Yeah, yeah, great album.
No, so, it's been a minute,
and you know, we've all grown up with her.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so, it was so cool.
I watched it from the
floor and then with Matt,
my friend Matt Rogers
and I went, and then we,
but then seeing the Eras Tour
movie is pretty incredible.
- Yeah, 'cause the movie came out, yeah.
- Yes, the movie came out.
- And it was everywhere.
I literally ate at a
restaurant here downstairs
and we were leaving.
Caitlin, who was serving us was like,
"Hey, and I made these bracelets."
And she said something and
for the debut or something.
And I was like, I just went along with it.
I was like, "Thank you.
"That is so nice."
And then I walked off and we were like
what are they talking about?
And they were, people are so into it.
They were making, people, just randos
are making like bracelets,
passing them out
to like she's got such an
incredible street team.
- I know.
- I was like, yeah.
- It's really amazing.
- But yeah, so the movie came out
and it like busted all these
stats and records.
- [Bowen] Records.
- Yeah, yeah.
Which is not shocking, it's Taylor.
- Not at all.
- Yeah, but I love that
you've been a fan for so long.
I think we've all been a fan of her music.
She's a great writer.
She's had so many great songs.